Michael would love to hear this infamous
will gear story you were at your alma
mater talking yeah we we shared a common
point an intersection in a fraternity
although he was at the university of
chicago 50 years earlier and i was at
Auburn University and I had written an
address for that fraternity which I
delivered in muncie indiana and they
recorded didn't know about the recording
part but then they started to play it
for distinguished alumni and they were
out doing interviews with members alumni
of that paternity and the entertainment
industry Dean Jagger who won the Academy
Award for Brigham Young Chester ghoul
who created Dick Tracy and will geer who
at that time was the grandfather on the
Waltons they played the thing for will
and he says in his imitable style you
know how to get in touch with this fella
and they said yeah he's at almond he
said call him and so I get over his
might literally the evening of my last
college final and I i went to the phone
in the end this he sits on this is will
gear I think you should try acting
before the corporate structure snaps you
up I said I don't know anything about it
mr. gears had come to California I work
with you and I I was you know I mean I
was taped needless to say I knew who he
was but I was taking it back I had no
idea you know they a preface the the
conversation a little bit and introduced
me to him it but I thought us may I call
you back because that never been on the
stage here and I I had no alief once in
the first grade no lines that was it and
I thought hmm and it was it was an
interesting time in the history of you
know of our country and culture and that
Vietnam was still raging and that's not
true it was winding down which is why i
was able to go to California I didn't
have to go to Vietnam and
I thought it's too rare and opportunity
I don't want to look back go what do you
and I knew I wanted out of the south so
I went out there and I knew nothing and
people said try it you won't make it try
it he won't make it Wow you don't know
what you're doing you will make it and
after a while I got a good resentment
about it and you can do a lot of good on
a good resentment so I just held on you
know but Ellen his daughter Ellen was
extraordinary was the original longitude
for tyrone guthrie and Ellen was the
primary director at theatrical botanica
and she taught me how to act she just
took me by the hand and taught me how to
act and it was not an easy task I
couldn't read I didn't read will I
Stamford and stuttered you know you walk
into an audition in your you're trying
to pick up a line that didn't work well
so I had to learn to read and I would
work construction during the day and I
was in the bathtub it now I didn't read
Time magazine until it sounded like
human speech and I can mechanically pick
words off a page and I'm probably still
a better reader thought I have an actor
because of that
you